Vice President Biden, Mr. Chief Justice,...
...members of the United States Congress,...
...distinguished guests and fellow citizens.
Each time we gather to inaugurate a President...
...we bear witness to the enduring strength of our constitution.
We affirm the promise of our democracy.
We recall that what binds this nation together is not the colors of our skin,...
...or the tenets of our faith,...
...or the origins of our names.
What makes us exceptional,...
...what makes us American,...
...is our allegiance to an idea articulated in a declaration made more than two centuries ago.
"We hold these truths to be self-evident,..."
"...that all men are created equal,..."
"...that they are endowed by their Creator with certain unalienable rights..."
"...that among these are life, liberty and the pursuit of happiness."
Today, we continue a never-ending journey...
...to bridge the meaning of those words with the realities of our time.